this is from The Daily Mail man we
really do like them don't we two women
who denied being trafficked by Andrew
Tate and his brother and insist they
worked for him willingly our victims and
have been brainwashed Romanian judge
rules so uh I guess it's believe all
women unless those women go against The
Narrative of the men you're trying to
imprison I'm actually struggling to
follow the grammar of this headline they
two women came out and said yo it's not
true we're not victims and the judge
went we were here nah you're brainwashed
we were not coerced we were here happily
and he's like no you don't understand
you were coerced you you were being I
don't know okay now this is a matrix
attack I'm sorry at this point yeah for
real because and by the way there are
they are they people are like are they
is it a major attack against Andrew Tate
or did he really do these things and I'm
like man you know honestly I don't know
now that a judge was like these two
witnesses who support Andrew Tate yeah
they're actually victims statements
here's my confusion is have the Tate
Brothers been charged no so what is the
ruling what does the ruling pertain to
this is why I'm like at this point it's
a matrix attack because I'm I'm off by
the way and I've said this for everybody
I've said this for Epstein I've said
this for um but I don't know if you guys
saw that that story The ABC producer the
guy who they thought was missing oh yeah
and then it turned out that he was
apparently like messaging kids on
Snapchat asking for porn all sorts of
crazy stuff
um that show me the evidence right show
me the evidence and let's have a fair
trial when it was Kyle Rittenhouse I
said you showed me the evidence when it
was Alec Baldwin I said show me the
evidence and you know he had a live
bullet in his gun he had live Ham on his
gun belt of course he had live out on
his gun belt the whole thing was live
and of course he was using the hammer
and of course he was playing around the
trigger I think I think he murdered her
I think he put the bull in it so did you
actually read the and an over jumping
stories but did you actually read the um
the probable cause uh summary no so
from my reading of it it didn't seem as
though the investigation turned up
actual footage of the shooting it said
in their investigation they were able to
uncover evidence of filming immediately
prior to the shooting with his finger on
the chair with his finger on the trigger
and he's fiddling with the with the
hammer which of course decreases the
pressure that it would require for a
long pull trigger Etc et cetera but
it didn't say that they had actual
footage of because if they had they
would just say it yeah right so it
didn't I don't think that they've
actually turned up footage of the
shooting I just think just to wrap that
one up and go back to the Andrew Tate
stuff real quick it's like he shot a
woman pulled a gun pulled the hammer
back pulled the trigger and everyone's
like oh it was an accident where'd the
live bullet come from he had them on his
belt like Alec Baldwin was in possession
of a gun right possession of live
ammunition pointed at a woman he was
having arguments with and shot her like
a staffer a staffer okay anyway the
Andrew Tate thing which by the way but
Tim what you're doing right now is
you're analyzing the evidence because
the evidence has been presented to us
yes and so now you can conclude a
illegal analysis based on the severity
the weight The credibility of that
evidence what we have here we have no
charges we have we have some statements
and apparently the judge is telling the
people who made the statements that
they're not allowed to make those these
are these are witnesses supporting the
Tate Brothers being told they did not
recognize that they were being enslaved
so when this happened and the question
was people are like is the machine
coming after him or did he do this and a
lot of people were like well you know
the things the things he said I'm like
at this point when you get Witnesses who
are like we're here to speak in in
support of this man and the judge goes
nah you're brainwashed get out all right
let's read that the they're a clinical
psychologist did an assessment
but judges of the Bucharest court of
appeal did take the report in
consideration over yesterday's decision
this is crazy dude so they found some
clinical psychologists
because of that assessment which which
by the way may also mean that if they're
going to take this rule so let's say
they are charged right let's say they
are charged and they go to court et
cetera et cetera does that mean that
these two women can now not appear as
Witnesses because they've already been
ruled against
I don't know I don't know I don't know
if this would be that this would be
excluded from them so it looks like they
were appealing the the actual
um because in Romania they have this
thing where you can be held while you're
under investigation as opposed to before
you recharged and then they I think it
was 30 days and they extended another 30
days I'm just kind of it's like 120 now
right right right so point being is
they're they're trying to fight that
initial detention I think they lost that
ruling already and well I think that's
the ruling that they're talking about
here yeah that so they they did away
with it my question is though does that
create a a pretext does that create a
situation where if they want to come in
and appear as witnesses to say excuse me
we're not victims we're Witnesses
um that they're already going to say no
probably that's what it seems like
that's literally what they're doing
they're saying that because the women
were lover boy traffic like they thought
they were in love or potentially going
to marry these guys that they can't
understand that they are actually being
recruited you know women have no agency
I guess don't I know it yeah they can't
make decisions for themselves apparently
so what you're saying is feel the 19th
Amendment
no I mean I'm just saying I mean isn't
that the obvious well so the in Romania
perhaps can women vote the underlying
the online text of this is exactly what
you just said though because the under
in this clinical psychologist and again
we're responding to what the court has
ruled we are not saying these things but
the logical conclusion of what you're
saying is that clearly that women have
no agency because men lie to them and so
women are not responsible for their
actions and if women are not responsible
for their actions and their decisions
then why should we put women in a
position where they they're making the
most important decisions uh life and
death War and Peace trade uh that we
should we should take this away from
them because these these evil men with
by the way Ian of course with these
Financial campaigns these well-funded
campaigns that are used against these
poor women that they're just being
victimized over and over and over and
that's why that's why we should take
this pressure this burden take a look at
this famous meme image
It's a poster it says Jake was drunk
Josie was drunk Jake and Josie hooked up
Josie could not consent the next day
Jake was charged with rape a woman who
was intoxicated cannot give her legal
consent for sex so proceeding under
these circumstances is a crime it only
takes a simple day to ruin your life
think about it be responsible I can't
read the bottom the woman has no agency
and is no not responsible for for raping
no doesn't say who who made it you can't
really see something University yes some
University yeah always I'm really
concerned about this consent
conversation because I understand if
someone is being trafficked in some way
or like put through some hell and they
are brainwashed into thinking that
everything's fine and then they come out
and they tell everyone hey everything's
totally fine and you're like okay I can
see that situation what do they call
that uh Stockholm syndrome where the
victim actually thinks that the the
captor is a good guy you know I get that
but at the same time if someone consents
to something no matter what if you sign
a contract under duress the contract
doesn't it's not a real contract so I
understand that when you prove it but
when I was back in Hollywood I was being
trafficked so take them all down this is
different like these women are trying to
say we are not under duress like how do
you prove that you're not under duress
if the court says you are right like
like if if you were accused of a crime
and then you bring two witnesses who say
we've worked with them they're good guys
we love and respect them and the judge
goes you're brainwashed dismissed you're
gonna stay in jail that's what I'm
talking about now look perhaps the
mistake the tape brothers made was
setting up a base of operations in
Romania of all places and I don't know
why they chose that place
because I mean it's not like Eastern
Europe is known for like being
anti-corrupt right it's like you take a
look at what's going on in Ukraine right
now it bit him back he said that's the
reason he was there is because you get
away with a lot of things but they
didn't think this would actually happen
you know of course it will yeah don't
exactly the thing about the US
I was talking to
um
well I'll keep the story relatively
perfect I don't know if it's public
story but they they do this race I
forgot what it's called they Race Across
Russia and because there's so much
corruption you can go 120 miles an hour
you get pulled over you just hand cash
to the cop and you're free to go you you
can't do that in the United States which
but by the way that's most countries in
the world right yeah not in the United
States though yeah we talk about a
political corruption but let's be honest
like cops tend to not be corrupt I mean
we have corrupt cops we have abusive
cops but I guarantee you if you get
pulled over and say to the cop you're
gonna offer my bribe he's gonna back out
of the car you're under arrest yeah no
that's just our politicians right
politicians are different they get
bribery from the lobbyist but a cop is
going to lock you up and be like I'm not
going down for what you just did I'm
taking the note you offered me a bribe
you're under arrest I think people in
general don't it's it's a strange
dichotomy where we believe that we're
relatively uh to to places like South
Africa for example hey American police
are are far more
um
far less corrupt I should say than
relatively than there or anywhere in in
some of these Eastern European
post-soviet countries but at the same
time our politicians are far far far
more corrupt than the politicians of
almost any other country
um we don't talk about it that way for
some reason but the amount of money that
and even you would just you just
explained it very well how it happens
that the amount of money that's able to
find their way into their pockets
whether I mean there's a reason that
like Gavin Newsom right go look at the
uh you know the maglev project the
high-speed rail of California that never
existed despite spending tens of
billions of dollars which of course was
washed back into his campaigns which was
washed back into his support uh that
went to all these developers and
consultants and environmental impact
surveys etc etc that the whole thing was
a money wash the same way that Libya and
Afghanistan the current situation these
are these are money washes by and large
and George Orwell wrote this when
talking about Warfare but you could talk
about it with a lot of these government
corrupt agencies that the the point of
the war is not so that it should be one
the point of the war is that it should
be continuous yeah yeah
money making machine I guess
I'm deeply concerned about this Andrew
Tate thing at this point this is really
this is really starting to bother me
because because these girls were very
plain that they they weren't being
roughed up by them that he wasn't that
they weren't being trafficked by them
they said it specifically said it out
loud to the judge and it was dismissed
like this is it they've made videos
about it where they're like this is not
true they're calling us victims we're
not victims and they're like yeah
they're just brainwashed I mean show me
the you know where's the evidence like
the passport was taken and it was put in
the safe and they were told that they
couldn't get the passport back and said
they were stuck in the country until
they worked off their their debt lay
that out for me right if that's what
happened show it to me show me the
evidence and I've I've always said this
name the names show me the evidence
let's have it all out I'm perfectly
happy with looking into any of those
situations but for some reason in this
case you don't seem to get that and by
the way and you know if that ends up
being what it is then okay so be right
right totally but show me that yes
exactly yeah the process is concerning
because I think they're treating the
process as the punishment kafka's book
um the trial in the original in the
original German the title is dear
process and the main character I can't
think of the naval taught my head but
the main character is he's charged at
the beginning he's brought into and this
is the in the 1920s and this is like
Weimar Germany he was writing that so
he's charged
he's brought in uh to jail he's told
that he's going to okay this is your
lawyer these are the different uh
arguments that you can make that's what
you could do at the trial he goes to
trial et cetera et cetera the very the
last scene of the whole thing he's being
drug away to his own execution but never
once in the book do they actually say
what he was charged for right exactly
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time